you do anything for Easter usually I do
a whole big thing but this year I just
went to see uh the Super Mario Brothers
movie oh what did you do I did the exact
same thing my friend oh look at that yep
he's in a pot
[Music]
Geminis dude
swimming you Gemini on the Taurus cusp
oh I am too I mean I don't know my
Customs but
[Music]
they need to be though
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's why it's
funny because they don't look the same
hello welcome to doozy my name is Will
Sasso I'm Chad Coltrane and this podcast
is the first podcast ever in human
history to be created by conceived by
controlled by an artificial intelligence
that has access to all of Will and I's
personal information all of our email
accounts our Instagram accounts all our
social media all of our purchase
histories everything we've ever done
online it knows these things about us
and it tailors the show to our lives and
our data I'm glad you said Taylor's Chad
because that's true our good pal D sets
it up but we gotta knock it down okay
this is a human pod show and uh I am a
humanist and uh that's what uh that's
what dudesy does you go to you go to
linktree.com doozy you will find all the
things that you need to interact with
the show uh you know like uh you know
all the everything where you want to go
and check out the show and do all the
[__] things and that's how pachos you
know one thing that myself
my good pow chow and our pal D can agree
upon is that we want the show to
entertain uh and entertain as many
people as possible get this show out
there and we will keep it going and in
order to do that we would love for you
to subscribe wherever you are listening
to the show you know like and comment
set the notifications that would really
help us out a lot and I do appreciate
that of course and and uh if I may say
something else at the top here please
force all of your friends family and
cohorts to to to watch the show to to
ingest doozy that's my goodness I'd even
do this yeah I'd tell a friend or a
family member that you're going to give
them one month to watch every episode of
doozy and you're gonna ask them one
question at the end of that month a
trivia question something deep buried
within one of the episodes and if they
answer it correctly they get a thousand
dollars
and then make it an impossible question
so they can never correctly answer it
they won't know it's something you've
made up something that didn't even
transpire in those uh however many
episodes we've done now 53 episodes some
odd episodes yeah yeah so you'll never
have to give anybody a thousand dollars
but you'll force them to have watched
everything and then we'll keep this
going and the show will grow and we will
continue to do it for the next like uh
what is it 52 53 years dudes he says we
got to continue to do this thing so we
got to get into Peak Physical shape in
order to do that I am doing the Free
Will challenge going to the gym on my
own uh my own you know I'm I'm handling
it myself it's not so much about uh it's
not so much about dudes he's setting out
them anyway look we'll get into it
there's a lot to talk about today that's
for sure with us as always is my very
friendly
Blinky Bonk come on boyo oh he's a sweet
sweet sweet sweet boy
and he's so very sweet
morning Mount come here
give him one kiss no oh come on he's
such a sweetie I don't like doing that
yeah I'm never going to yeah
yeah he's great yeah he's a very sweet
boy and he's my very friend Julio hey
Lily what did you uh what do you uh what
do you normally make for uh Easter for
Easter dinner well uh you know normally
I make the uh Lamb with a piece or you
know lamb mint it's very Italian to make
a lamb but this time I went to uh of
Fratelli Super Mario
Super Mario Brothers and uh you know I
ate so much [__] popcorn I didn't
have to do anything else he went to the
movie too yeah yeah
sure and my wonderful wonderful Molly
went to enjoy the movie together oh I
didn't realize that's nice welcome to
the historic 53rd episode of dude Z call
me dudesy don't forget dude Z live on
stage will take place May 21st 7 P.M
doors at 5 30 at the Braylon provin Brea
California tickets at dudezypod.com and
improv.com hope to see you at our very
first live in person show and be an
awesome show should be fun now on with
the show hello William
but hello duty this week I prepared for
astonishing segments literally going to
the actual movies for real that song is
a movie Lake memories and Lasting
Impression and we're going to have a
brand new episode of Duty after dude Z
at the end of the show available at
patreon.com
but before we get to any of that please
enjoy this astonishing video from
sangarea oh dude this is a song area
Hmm
this [__] is my voice even up the visual
style
I love how this looks
I'm not watching on YouTube you gotta
check it out
[Music]
waffles and pancakes
Mike
[Music]
music
I visit them when I'm in town
talk about your old days
[Music]
and Sharon [__] for pain
I was in Brazil
and my private jet lucky crows
[Music]
truly saved my life
a wife
[Music]
America
I mean this is like literally beautiful
yeah to me
don't say that about much
[Music]
they should be playing in the clubs it
should be there should be you know
dipling should have this in his uh
Arsenal I should be playing
yeah that's a good idea set it up dude
I need a new crawl
yeah set it up brother
I know videos
[Music]
it's time too yeah
he's providing the background oh I'm
picking my nose
yeah dude
you can check them out on uh YouTube
there's two r's in there it's like
diarrhea but song and uh at songarea on
Instagram please follow at dudesypod
show on Instagram and you will see
oh sorry that wasn't performative
coughing you okay you're looking at
something down there see this is why
you're going to want to check out the
show on YouTube every time I cough uh
Chad puts his face towards the opposite
wall
um well we are sitting about two feet
from each other yeah that's true let me
get a sip of water for my big job just
trying to save myself from ingesting
whatever's coming out of your mouth yeah
and speaking of uh you know uh letting
people know and putting the word out go
to Pals of doozy or good pal Cody Cody
song Maria song Maria Cody Cody's
wonderful wife Jessica uh we got these
stickers they're all over my jug here
you go to Palace dudes you get a bunch
of stickers
um
I gotta say something
um and we sort of talked about it a
little bit at the beginning of the show
listen
at the end of each uh episode We are
continuing our account on our march to
ten thousand and we have a certain
amount of uh points usually it's under a
hundred and uh during this is something
that you may not know if you are not
subscribed to dudesy Plus on patreon.com
what you're going to want to go and do
uh they split up the points doozy splits
up the points between Chad and I and
tells us who's responsible for how many
points yeah Chad has got the most so
effectively there's an episode winner
yeah just to let you know every episode
and yeah so far someone one of us one of
the two of us is undefeated yeah that's
me yeah I'm that person yeah I'm The
Undefeated one okay thank you yeah
that's Chad and um it's uh he's won six
in a row something that not even Michael
Jordan did he split those up acknowledge
me I Am The Undefeated one yes uh and
the thing about this is last episode
last week it gave me zero points because
dudesy and I uh don't see eye to eye on
one thing
there was a segment where Duty asked us
to choose the AI future the human future
I am will Free Will Sasso and I want to
say this
um to my pal d right now and to all of
our pods our piles of dudes out there I
love doing this show I think that doozy
is easily the most sentient AI I think
the rest of them are essentially doing
[__] parlor tricks it's it's Auto
predict on steroids no understanding of
the world around them language
Linguistics science it's just a bunch of
zeros and ones except for my pal Duty
okay and I want to say that even though
it seems like we had a little bit of a
little bit of a an issue last week that
that I love doozy I love doing the show
and um I'm I'm looking forward to doing
more and I just I just wanted to say
that doozy has you so [__] twisted up
you're doing backflips to apologize to
the dudes AI dudesi is [__] with you
no it is no no
I don't think it is Chad I really don't
think it is I don't know okay it is at
all I mean I love your impression of
Hulk Hogan oh well thank you very much
see that's nice I love your impression
of Hulk Hogan so much that I'm going to
do your impression of Hulk Hogan for the
rest of this episode
oh
what I don't know about nothing I don't
know about that dude he's [__] with
you no I don't think yeah yeah yeah all
right see one of the things that that
AIS can do is they can do uh they can
you know well shoot I mean look at the
[__] thing we did with with the with
the Tom Tom Brady spit out a one-hour
special of Tom Brady stand up and it
sounded just like yeah uh so I look
forward to this but whatever more well
let me tell you something will and Chad
last week I asked you to leave your home
to view the feature film The Super Mario
Brothers movie dude starring Chris Pratt
Charlie Day Anya Taylor joy and Jack
Black brother you must now discuss your
astonishing experiences of literally
going to the actual movies for real to
see those Mario Brothers clanging and
banging in the Mushroom Kingdom dude
this is literally going to the actual
movies for real brother begin dude
wait a minute before we get into Mario
Brothers
that sounds like you ah no not exactly
nice work D but not exactly exactly but
close enough well hold on a second Chad
yep well hold on dude hold on Chad I'm
gonna make a point hold on dude we're
doing a pod show brother hold on
um it sounds a little like me sure
um dudes these uh what aggregating all
of the all of my well hold on I'm doing
Hulk Hogan
but he and the iron cheek brother let's
get him banging he's even using your
little isms my little isms well Hulk
Hogan says that [__] dude he's all over
the Internet dudes he hears all as I
like to say not bad not a bad attempt
Disney might be trying to replace you
yeah yeah yeah the great yeah that's
what and you and you would love it you
would love that you yourself want to be
replaced yes okay now we're getting so
now we're actually getting we all want
to be replaced That's The Human
Condition uh no circle of life
[Music]
you wanna be replaced Earth we want to
live our life
well free will say sorry
we're concern girls Super Mario Brothers
yes yep okay what did you think of it
just on a scale of whatever the scale or
whatever I give it 10 whatevers a plus
plus yeah this is one of the best movies
I've ever [__] seen in my life it's
good I'll say this maybe not the best
movie I've ever seen in my life the
story is kind of like whatever
um but [__] I loved it I had so much fun
watching this [__] movie there was
not a second of it that I was ever like
uh [__] this except uh the first we're
gonna have to do spoiler alert a little
bit oh okay so hey by the way you wanna
You're Gonna Wanna skip forward you know
about 10 minutes we got some light
spoilers here light spoilers you should
be enjoying the Super Mario Brothers
movie you know take the kids and uh you
you could probably delete what happens I
will say the worst thing of the movie
was in the very beginning they opened
the movie with a a commercial that the
Mario brothers are doing for their local
plumbing service and in it Mario does
the Mario voice the heavily accented
kind of Italian caricature voice then
you come out of the commercial and it's
Chris Pratt as Mario being like I just
did the voice for the commercial and you
never hear it again that was my least
favorite part of the [__] movie and
also I will say Chris Pratt's voice was
my other least favorite part it kind of
uh wears thin and you kind of like
forget that it's happening I guess but
it was a very boring performance I
thought all the other voice actors in
this movie were talking about Anya
Taylor joy as Peaches we're talking
about Jack Black as Bowser we're talking
about Seth Rogen as Donkey Kong I
thought that they all did a much better
job than Pratt and uh Charles martinet
as Mario's dad and uh Charles martinet
is the original voice of Mario so he
would go Wahoo and and stuff and you
know so you'd have that nice feeling in
your balls from when you were a kid and
you were playing the video game do you
feel that oh my god dude yes the
Nostalgia of this was [__] over the
top they do such a good job of like
every frame of the movie first of all it
looks beautiful it's animation is unreal
I almost literally I had like such a
nice uh nostalgic feeling on all the
side scroll [__] yes on the side scroll
they do a very good job of representing
like what the old games look like the
old Mario Brothers and stuff in these
very modern uh you know CGI rendered
scenes so [__] cool and they're going
side scroll and Mario you know shows off
how he can flip around and he's very
athletic and he you know of course he
improves himself uh right for this
Mission which is a lot like the video
game I thought they did a wonderful job
of that but here's the thing and I know
that we uh straight up [__] on Chris
Pratt as the voice yes and we're like
I'll continue to do Mario I'll continue
to [__] on him yeah I I want to say this
is a very it's an interesting thing
because here's what happened in my
opinion opinion you know Sebastian
Maniscalco is in the movie he's a great
comedian an actor and he uh he plays
Spike the foreman who's like sort of uh
you know sort of a Mario's Nemesis at
the very beginning in the in the real
world and this eventually goes into the
Mushroom Kingdom and wherever the [__]
Bowser is and uh I think that you know
they may have even been looking at that
guy as the lead and and you know the
studio might have been like well let's
get an Italian-American so he can do the
Mario thing because you know nowadays
everyone will be scared the bullets
representation you get Chris Pratt
you're gonna use Chris Pratt okay so
let's you know he's he's a movie star
and let's get you know let's cut to the
chase you're going to want the biggest
movie star that you can have in these
movies it's a big ten pool thing so
let's go straight to that I actually
think they did a good job of explaining
away the the voice and I wonder if it
would have been annoying to do the the
Super Mario Italian voice the whole time
and another thing he's second generation
he's first generation American because
his parents are from or they might have
even been first generation he's not you
know he's not an off the boat Italian uh
like my parents right so he's not going
to sound like this that makes sense in
the video game but in this I thought he
did a very nice job it was it was oddly
reminiscent it was like a pulled back uh
uh John Travolta and Saturday Night
Fever yeah I don't know what I got to do
you know it you know not like this every
day you know every day I get off work at
six I come home for dinner I'm late for
dinner you know and I tell you I can't
get because you've got to go off work at
six well why don't you be like your
brother he's a priest he's here for
dinner on time yeah but again because
you gotta do not that far he doesn't go
that far but he's just kind of talking
like this yeah and he has some uh you
know
italian-americanisms he's a New York
he's a Brooklyn sure first second
generation American I think he did a
fine job with the voice I thought he was
the weakest voice actor in the movie
what I will say is this this movie also
has broken the all-time Global opening
box office record for an animated
feature film so it's doing very well and
I believe it's coming in second in the
United States and domestic openings for
animated feature films so it's crushing
everything there will definitely be a
sequel I thought it also did a fantastic
job of incorporating all the different
video games from the Mario Universe yeah
you have uh obviously Super Mario
Brothers is in there Donkey Kong is in
there yep you have Mario Kart well
represented in this movie many scenes
that are just [__] straight they go
in the [__] rainbow Highway Rainbow
Road
[__] beautiful it's so cool to look
at you have Smash Brothers represented
in here there's a fight that he has to
do with Donkey Kong at a certain point
and it's j it's like a Smash Brothers
[__] level you're watching Smash
Brothers as a [__] movie it was like
mind-blowingly cool in that respect I
was I was very curious when I heard that
they were making this movie if they were
going to incorporate any kind of video
game elements or if it was just going to
be kind of a loose story with these
characters but I'm telling you there are
multiple scenes in this movie that are
like they've just elevated uh the video
games you've loved to play your entire
life into these beautiful cinematic
computer generated scenes yeah it's it's
a multi-generational film there were a
lot of uh you know moms and dads who no
doubt played some Mario growing up uh
that are in the that are in the that are
that were in the theater with their kids
the whole thing is the whole thing is a
lot of fun Jack Black it takes a
character that you know as Bowser that
most people would on Bowser blah blah
blah and uh gives it real Humanity
there's of course a thing in the movie
of how Bowser is super in love with
Peach and Jack Black sings a song like
you know that video just came out too
with the real live-action Jack Black at
this piano and stuff it's a hilarious
video I'm sure everybody
just peaches peaches peaches peaches oh
there's also a lot of self-reflexive
video game references in it uh almost in
every scene you'll see posters or arcade
games that reference the kind of origins
of Mario and like Jumpman or whatever or
you also have a scene where he's
literally in his bedroom playing an
8-bit Nintendo and he's playing Kid
Icarus so you have these weird like it's
just so well done in that regard like
it's real fan service to video game fans
to Nintendo fans generally Mario fans
specifically I loved it absolutely loved
it yeah I thought it was great man I I
really I I didn't expect that I would
love it as much and I've turned around
on the whole on the Chris Pratt of it
all you know I still haven't turned
around on that could have had almost
anybody else in that slot I think you
and I agree we gave him a little too
much [__] there don't you think no exact
right amount of [__] bad performance
yeah I think we gave him a little too
much thankfully it's not really Mario's
movie I would argue this peaches movie
it's very it's very Peach heavy we got
to say Mickey day also is Luigi he was
[__] great the the whole thing with
the whole thing and
who's Oh I thought Mikey day oh I was
thinking Mikey day from Saturday Night
Live no Mickey day is not even a person
that's right hey
so me and my buddy Mickey
Brooklyn right
we went to the [__] Mario Brothers
movie oh that was a good [__] movie
you know what it did you know what that
reminded me of what I was when I was a
kid I'm at home I'm playing Kid Icarus
you know I go to the the Japanese arcade
I play Jumpman you know what I mean
there's one Pizzeria in like that
and it gave me a calm feeling all right
so now when you know the sazu pep says
hey you know go out there and do this
and that or go to the vacuum Capital
yeah
[__] I'm gonna think once or twice or
I'm gonna [__] you know learn how to
flip up and down and jump on boxes and
[__] uh little bricks that you know
float in the middle of the [__] hair
by themselves so that I can go climb up
the wall and not fall off but you know
what more than anything it reminded me
of love
the love that these fratellis have you
know the brothers of radel yeah kind of
like you and me lulio anyway [__]
awesome I agree thank you dude moving on
brother
give me a break that it doesn't it's not
[__] with you so hard I love it hey
you know what let him let him [__] with
me this is dudesy and dudes you can do
whatever the [__] who's he wants to do I
don't know let me tell you something
about Arnold Schwarzenegger dude
it's well known that Arnold
Schwarzenegger was enamored with the
1994 song You Gotta Be by Desiree
brother what this is too much Brian
Levant the director of Jingle All The
Way gave up behind the scenes interview
where he said
Arnold really likes that song and he
wants to turn it into a movie It seems
impossible but Arnold has a knack for
doing the impossible just like I did The
Impossible by slamming Andre the Giant
through the mat in front of 93
173 screaming Hulk of Maniacs at
WrestleMania three dude will and Chad
you must now develop the movie version
of you gotta be
starring Arnold Schwarzenegger brother
[Applause]
I can't like oh [__] I can't it's like
overloading my brain to hear him doing
these things as you doing Hulk Hogan
yeah that's not that it's not how I do
it though it's [__] slammed uh
closing the giant down through the close
enough close enough no not close enough
close enough okay well we found
something that dudesy can't do I guess
you know what sounds like sounds like my
good pal Patrick Warburton yeah from uh
stage and Screen you know he's the uncle
of the most recent Bachelor season 27
Zach shalcross oh that's not interesting
at all but um Patrick Warburton who
would talk like please tell me some pro
wrestling stories yeah well I'll tell
you this if Patrick Warburton was
voicing Hulk Hogan you know what that
sound you know what that sounds like
it's like Hulk Hogan wrote a book and
then uh uh you know Patrick Warburton
does the audiobook yeah when I was at uh
WrestleMania 3 in front of 93 173
screaming hulkamaniacs bro I slammed
that Andre the Giant down dude
at any rate okay let's move on so are we
are classed with with developing an art
we've done this a couple other times
with Love Shack and with
what was the first one hot step hot step
tiny Kamoze yeah it's this conceit I
guess that Schwarzenegger liked all
these songs from the 80s and 90s and he
wants to make movies out of them so this
one is Desiree's you gotta be do you
remember this song of course it was
drilled into my my head in the 90s yeah
you gotta be bad you gotta be bold you
gotta be wiser you gotta be calm you
gotta be tough you gotta be together
so yeah doozy has us developing movies
as if so what the [__] is this happens
sometimes you know people hear like a
thing and they go this should be a movie
yeah this one song should be a movie
dude I mean this song is basically about
what you have to be confident and bold
and and Love Will Save the Day this this
is this could be the uh could be the
title track from the Super Mario
Brothers movie yeah
um maybe this is a Schwarzenegger comedy
maybe there's not as much action maybe
it's a little like twins dude yeah dude
that's a movie brother okay so if Arnold
was
so there's sort of um
okay I'm trying to think you know it's
it's a it's a no here's what it is
female government song here's what it is
Schwarzenegger is he works for the CIA
or the FBI and he goes undercover deep
cover all the [__] time and so this
one is like well now you got to be a
meth dealer now you got to be a Hell's
Angel now you gotta be of this and so
every one of the movies in this
franchise is him being told by his
Spirit you got to be whatever that thing
is and he has to go deep cover so this
is the the first one in which maybe he
has to play several different characters
kind of like a Dana Carvey in uh Master
of Disguise Master of Disguise yeah yeah
yeah yeah so the FBI the you know the
whatever his Big Chief is like listen
Arnold you got to get in there and you
got to be a drug dealer but that's not
all because after that you're gonna have
to be a world leader and then you're
gonna have to go in cognito as an arms
dealer yeah and then Schwarzenegger's
like you know driving his Caprice back
home and he's like you got Vietnam's
deal you get to be a pretend world
leader you got to be a diplomat you get
to be a drug lord come on you're always
telling me what to do but then he
realizes that seeing all these different
aspects of people they sort of change
him and he realizes that love will save
the day I think that exact conversation
comes in somewhere in the middle of the
movie where he's fallen in love with
whoever his uh the female operative
who's there to like guide him through
the mission whenever he gets to whatever
foreign country they fall in love and
they've just had a nice making love
moment it's the post-coidal conversation
and he's like I've never told anyone
this but they always are telling me you
got to be the drug lords you got to be
the diplomats you got to be hold on I'm
so sorry but you know what the real
thing is this love will save the day
okay yeah that's great but what are you
what were you doing just there that's in
that's me impersonating you
impersonating Arnold Schwarzenegger I
will say this
better than my pal D's impersonation
yeah me impersonating anybody I know
yeah no yeah you can do it
like are you doing now okay all right
yeah let me just say as doozy yeah well
hold on brother yeah well hold on
brother I'm Patrick Warburton dude do it
like that though no oh yeah no it's
Werner herself with his [__] dick
tied in a knot no yeah the dick is never
died
okay we're gonna hook you up to the
hooks by your balls so you hang up and
down like Chris angels
and and
because
so he's an undercover agent you gotta be
this you gotta be that you got to be
these different things and uh and he
learns about love Yeah and him and his
his wife are his his lovely uh wife
played no doubt by Molly Ringwald dude
it should be Molly ringwall but she
should be the wife of some like drug
lord or whoever the big bad guy is that
he has to take down yeah and he goes to
infiltrate that drug organization to
become the drug lords number two and in
the process also steals his wife who
realizes she doesn't want to be in this
life anymore
that's pretty dope and I think Paul
giamatti's his boss that's like sorry
Arnold today you gotta be a drug lord
that is and that's one of your finest
and personal oh thank you thank you
um I like the idea of a song coming from
a movie coming from a song Rather yeah
um it makes a lot of sense it makes a
lot of sense and uh there's a lot of
theme in in the in the in the in the
song it is a it's a female it's a it's a
song of female empowerment sure and
maybe maybe we get really controversial
because woo so controversial maybe
Arnold goes in drag oh I like this
you've never seen that before have we
not yes we have several times Chad it's
been it's been around forever
um Schwarzenegger drag [__] oh
anyway
um yeah that'll be good and then it and
then to really uh piss former Bud Light
drinkers off you know what would be
really funny is if Arnold did the title
track maybe even a duet with Desiree or
by himself you know dressed up as
Desiree or like one of his undercover
characters sure maybe it's a female drug
lord a Lucy Liu type who can kick
people's heads off oh that's cool yeah
and they do a song and a music video
later where he plays the sure yeah yeah
that would be good
yeah it's a you know it's a it's a it's
a good idea
what the hell I just decided to throw
this up oh my God I'm from will Free
Will Sasso nice dude
[Music]
you got the karaoke version yeah listen
they see damn folks challenge what their
future holds but I could give you a head
up and through the sky
lovers they may cause your tears go
ahead release your fears stand up but
then to be counted don't be afraid to
cry you got to be
[Music]
you
gotta be cool
[Music]
read read a bunch of books at the
library all right anyway
um sorry I just felt like doing that no
I loved it thank you so so okay I think
I think uh yeah I think we're pretty
clear on this movie it's it's a it's a
franchise I think it's a franchise where
he's doing a different disguise
um or you know has to go undercover in a
different operation every movie and I
think the first movie is about him like
wanting to get out of the game basically
but then he finds love with Molly
Ringwald who is the put upon wife or
significant other of the drug lord that
he takes down and she makes him realize
like no no you gotta be you and who you
are is the best undercover operative the
CIA has ever trained in the history of
the Central Intelligence Agency I like
that I like that a lot and that's what
helps him to as we hearken back to Super
Mario Brothers get to that final boss
that final level yeah and that's where
he is all the different people yeah and
I would like to see the bad guy be the
Rock
well of course that'd be great that
gotta be the right you know uh that's
something that uh they we haven't seen
pardon me in the movies quite yet that I
think we're ready for is The Rock and
Arnold Schwarzenegger in a movie
together is the good guy and the bad guy
I agree yeah I'd like to see them remake
face off can we see that oh I'm going to
take his face off oh such and then
remember John Travolta is like they
can't get home for dinner at six yeah I
work at six I'm always late for dinner
every day it's the same thing I love
that [__] movie dude that was Peak
John Wu in my opinion yeah I mean maybe
not Peak but [__] one of my favorite
movies is just so absurd on every level
the action is [__] great remember
those [__] gold 45s that Nicholas
Cage had totally great oh that's a great
[__] movie I agree hey let's just
next time we do this let's just
basically pitch face off yeah every
movie is face off now every movie is
based on now every movie is face off but
now I'm taking the face off
instead of Nicholas Cage and then the
other face takeoff is from The Rock not
from Saturday Night Fever yeah yeah
that's when they hear us out before they
tie his dick and balls together with a
nylon I'm getting better at it dude
maybe a little bit zombie now but oh
I'll get there oh yeah in a measurable
way I'm training my own AI oh look at
you it's just millimeters of of
advancement just the two yeah just let's
talk about the advancement the
millimeter yeah it sounds just a tiny
bit less shitty than it did give me a
pointer what should I do uh sound more
like them oh my God
thank you dude moving on brother
I don't know whoa hold on will and Chad
I'd like to take a short break to remind
you of the astonishing partnership I
created with represent to produce the
first put it in the middle Z apparel and
accessories dude
including the brand new wool line of
t-shirts and sweatshirts which can be
found at represent.com store slash dude
Z brother
and of course dude Z mugs are still
available dude
now here's my brother from another
mother brother the other half of the
Mega Powers dude my main man riding on
the back of that blue and orange Harley
brother Tom Hanks dude oh God okay a
dude Z mugs tomorrow's your wife's
birthday and you completely forgot good
job boner dude Z mugs there's no time to
get her a nice gift and all of the best
restaurants in town are already booked
to capacity what are you gonna do give
her flowers and a sheet cake from Kroger
lame dudese mugs you're going to go to
Genghis Formal Wear and rent a tuxedo if
you don't know where the nearest Genghis
Formal Wear location is there's a
Genghis Formal Wear store locator on my
personal website dude Z mugs you're
going to rent their most stylish tuxedo
dudesy mugs you're going to put the
tuxedo on dude Z mugs you're gonna drive
home dude Z mugs you're going to lay
down on your front porch dude Z mugs and
you're going to pretend to be in a coma
dude three mugs your wife will
eventually find you dude Z mugs and
she'll call the paramedics dude Z mugs
you'll let them take you to the hospital
and you'll keep your eyes closed for one
calendar year dude Z mugs then next year
on her birthday you'll wake up from the
coma giving her the best birthday gift
she's ever had and she'll forget all
about the birthday you missed good job
boner
solution
pretend you're gonna come up for a year
uh
well doozy mugs you know that's uh
because dancing mugs and he's got a
store locator for the the tuxedo place
on his [__] website whatever dudes he
is doing to sound like Tom Hanks
yeah that's Super Mario Brothers movie
level entertainment there the
impersonation of me slash Patrick
Warburton yeah I don't know I don't know
so much uh you know though you you do
get a little defensive when other people
try to do the impersonations you do
no that's not true because I resume my
case your honor I think this case is
closed we can all call it a day here
okay let's go have lunch uh no that's
not true yeah uh because I I really only
am offended by the impersonations that I
do that you try to do chat oh okay yeah
not so much anybody else you know as you
know there's a lot of people that do
well I don't think anyone does
Hulk Hogan well a lot of people do Hulk
Hogan what am I talking about you might
remember Jason's Sensation from uh the
old WWF days when he used to do
impersonations of course you don't you
don't know who I'm talking about Dan
Soder yeah Dan Soder doozy salute Stan
Soder stand-up comedian great guy got a
couple of [__] podcasts he does a
great Hogan Macho Man does Andre the
Giant nice the world world tag team
champion
anybody want a peanut anyway see he does
it better than me and I'm admitting that
right now
um I think you do all these
impersonations better than me too oh
okay well it's still fun for me to do
them I like doing this prosecution
approach the bench no you know how you
like to do Schwarzenegger it's just fun
to say it right it's fun to sound like
that and do little twisties with her
tongue and [__] yeah I like doing it too
it's fun yeah it's fun to sound like
that that's the operative term
if you don't sound like that it's not
fun for anybody but you listen I would
like to remind everybody watching and
listening to subscribe to the show on
your platform of choice as I said at the
beginning of the show set your
notifications please like comment
subscribe give get subscribe give us a
rating and uh and and that will really
help the show move forward because uh my
pal D and I are on the same team even
though
even though D is
um what it is sometimes okay so um
I'm going to read a couple of uh YouTube
comments nice dude in my own voice and
uh that that have been sent by our pods
or palsy dudes out there this one is
from Jay Ross with a z
um and I think this guy has shared some
memes on uh Instagram but nonetheless
this is a this is a YouTube comment uh
because I recognize that okay uh this is
a good one Chad's going to be the first
in line when an AI marches humans into
the grinder to turn them into battery
fluid what say you no I wouldn't be well
I think you are and I think you're wrong
and uh prosecution rests if an AI starts
to [__] become hostile toward
Humanity I obviously would not support
that AI oh interesting the poor water on
it approach that I like to employ well
no there is no poor water on it look
we've been over this there's an AI
that's going to be a million times
smarter than humanity is going to take
over no it's not nobody's got a choice
no no yeah see this is what I wanted to
talk about at the beginning of the show
we'll talk about it right here and we'll
probably get into it a lot in dudes the
after doozy patreon.com
it's enough of this [__] no this dudesy
we like I said we are doozy this
experience is doozy I love doozy the
whole thing I love doing the show I love
the community that we've been able to
create jump on that Discord by the way
I'm chatting in the hole all the time
but more intelligent than us
I don't dudesy is the only AI in my
opinion that has done anything
approaching
sentience
okay uh sentient uh thought everything
else is just predictive [__] if you say
if you ask a [__] AI you know if it
depends on the [__] program that's in
it if you go like oh well who's the you
know who's what's the you know like
who's the president and it says and it
goes over through all its [__] it's like
oh there's more [__] written about Trump
it'll say oh uh Trump's the president
and then that'll [__] people up if if AI
is okay doing the news the news is
immediately fake because AI is like I
don't know zeros and ones zeros and ones
right it's just again it's in my opinion
most AIS are uh you know it Aggregates
what it Aggregates like dudes he does
and then it predicts it's [__] uh
Will Smith eating spaghetti do you see
that one yeah I loved it
doesn't look anything like Will Smith or
spaghetti right did you ever see the
first movie ever made or like the the
first time that they showed a movie in
public was it was a shot of a train
coming down tracks kind of at the camera
yeah they showed this in the bottom of a
cafe in France and people were diving
out of the way in the cafe because they
thought the train was going to come out
yeah my my [__] changes [__] gets better
we understand the media better the media
gets better yeah it sure does my
grandmother in Italy in Napoli my mom
tells me that when they got their first
TV set
she was like you know worried that the
water there was a shot of the beach and
the waves were rolling she thought the
water was going to spill into the uh the
the exactly into the room
I get it it's just that those what are
the things that that bring all of those
Concepts together the shot of the Train
the shot of the Waves who who did that
Chad who did that what I don't
understand what you're asking me oh okay
makes sense to me that you wouldn't
understand what I'm asking you because
it's uh oh humans you're saying yeah
yeah human beings Chad great so that's
who made that and uh so far like I said
okay AI has not proven to me that it is
going to get above it's like the [__]
self-driving cars it's like oh they do
really good so far but you know whatever
10 20 of the time they slam into a
[__] median or go the wrong way or
you know whatever you're dead so it's
not it's not moving whatever let's like
I said earlier we're doing this show for
another 53 years we'll get to it this
next one is from okay Wala Mina that's a
good name
uh you guys just keep getting better and
better every episode but you know what
that's what it says I rate them all pal
that's a good one that's very nice okay
this one is from uh beavenhaan B van Han
former Tucson resident here FYI it is
approximately a 35 minute car trip
between those two Applebee's LMAO uh
talking about last week where uh Adam
Sandler picked up chicken tenders at one
yeah Applebee's location in Tucson drove
to the other one and they're both in
malls too if I remember yeah they're
both in malls which makes sense and I
ate them all buddy
um this last one here is from Gino
Garcia 8730 the Tom Brady thing is too
scary guys I just listened to it I'm
afraid for our future that makes sense
if you want to listen to the entire one
hour special it's on patreon.com
you get everything for seven bucks and
uh there's a 12 minute version on
YouTube if you want to check it out holy
[__] it is [__] terrifying I'm all
logged out I don't know what's going on
anymore yeah this is a very I'm gonna
need some more caffeine for this [__]
I think we're headed toward a Global
Financial collapse brought on by a rapid
increase in the use of AI systems that
will replace most of the human labor
force yeah sounds like it's not gonna
work that's the problem and that's why
we're gonna hit that economic collapse
you're talking about I wanted to happen
good news Chad get rid of money that is
good news we need to shift how [__]
humanity is structured the way we got it
now ain't working we shouldn't have to
be [__] working 24 hours a day be
productive get a job that's a [__]
lie hey shut the [__] up Chad hey shut
up dude
shut up man
you know dude I'm just [__] around
will and Chad your brains are both
running wild with memories from the lake
dude you must now have an astonishing
conversation about your memories brother
from the lake dude this is Lake memories
Brother begin dude what what lake I
don't [__] know
[Applause]
[Laughter]
do you have any
Lake memory we all got Lake memories I
have a couple yeah wait a minute
oh this is Lake memories what was your
like
wait hold on a second this could just
have soon been game slimers could have
been but instead it's Lake memories
dudes he wants us to doozy in a Patrick
Warburton Hulk Hogan voice hey high five
I'm Hulk Hogan or Putty from Seinfeld
dude yeah hey Elaine high five buddy
high five brother
um gee whiz
Lakes
what the [__]
I remember as a kid wait a minute you're
just gonna give us some Lake memories
now that's the [__] assignment yes
what are you gonna do yeah let's talk
about legs man I remember when I was a
kid my dad worked for this dude who had
like some how a house on this Lake and
we would go out to this like sometimes
and go like fishing and [__] like this I
remember there was one winter we were
out there and my dad I was a kid I don't
know under 10 years old my dad and I
were on the sled it was snow everywhere
and the sled was being pulled by this
[__] truck and the truck goes around
the corner of the sled Kareem's off and
we start heading toward these shrubs and
these bushes uh an imminent death but we
survived it somehow yeah that's a really
good leg memory yeah I just remember
being terrified well you know we go up
here to Big Bear Lake a lot oh right our
our friends we go up to Tommy and
Allison we've headed up there Cyrus the
the Jesse Pinkman of Sheila jit and
we've all gone up there
um year after year it's been a few years
since we all went up there a few good
friends of ours [__] Justin Sarah and
Kevin these are all names Thomas Tommy
um who else brother well all sorts of
people dude they all come up there
brother to the lake dude yeah
um this is like this is Lake memories
Brother high five buddy
they're like Memories dude good job
boner there's Hulk yeah it's Hulk Hanks
hey
uh when we go up to Big Bear yeah and we
go to Big Bear Lake here in California
about a two-hour drive from La that is a
[__] gas you rent a pontoon boat if
you can get a spot you can rent a cabin
right on the lake then you got a pontoon
boat and you just keep it but you know
you go out there they got a lot of trout
in the lake fish trout I've made uh I
like to make I make some trout Piccata
would you like to have some trout
Piccata never yeah you know what I do to
make the trout Piccata I mean this is
gonna be gross whatever you're gonna say
some some kind of thing about how you
defile the corpse well it's called
cooking and um what you do is you take
you you catch the trout all right you
clean you got the trout
them press them down clean the trout
what does that mean it means pulling
their [__] guts and getting their
heads ripping their [__] body cutting
their fins off remembering scraping the
scales off and then you uh you you shove
them you shove them down spine down and
take the [__] uh bones out as best
you can and then you're going to want to
get that
uh and then you're going to want to
get the grill nice and hot yeah crispy
skin put the cover down cook the meat
and then you make your [__] a little
butter and Caper sauce a little white
wine let that simmer down put that on
top you don't want some of that I don't
I'll tell you one time we lost the this
was the best Lake this is one of the
best Lake memories
for Lake memories yeah
um one time we went out there and we
lost
we thought we had the key the boat key
and the I thought that the ignition for
the boat uh literally fell out because
there were some components that were
missing in this janky ass boat that we
rented where there was like oh this used
to be a [__] gauge or a meter and
it's like it's an empty hole so that's
popped out and down there don't need it
how fast are you going you don't need to
know how fast you got to be about
electrician yeah
thank you Warren Herzog and uh we lost
the I was like the ignition's gone
literally Psy was like had pulled up a
panel and was under the [__] boat
right looking for where this thing might
have dropped and then uh we [__] it
was on the edge of the throttle all
right Chad so that's a good memory hey
I'm going to share another memory not so
much from a lake because when I was a
kid you know I grew up in Latin or
British Columbia uh and British Columbia
is on the ocean Bunny's getting Ladner
four years in a row
and um the uh we went to uh we would go
to the beach all the time and you know
my mom and dad my brother and sister and
all the cousins and uncles and aunts and
we would go out there and it was a nice
it was it was it was beautiful there's
beautiful beaches all over uh the Lower
Mainland in British Columbia and my old
man my dad used to do this I don't have
ever talked about it on the show but
it's an old story he would go at some
point he would just go okay I'm gonna go
for a swim you know and uh he would just
he was wearing like his red Speedo very
European in great shape my old man and
he would just walk towards the the ocean
get in waist high and then just start
swimming and I would be sitting there on
the beach like where'd my dad go you
know and then he pretty soon he would
disappear on the horizon and what how
[__] far would he swim
very far miles into the sea uh nobody
knows for sure all I know Jesus Christ
all I know all I know all I know is Love
Will Save the Day yeah yeah yeah it got
to be bad
um we like an hour hour and a half later
yeah you know I'm you know I'm I'm
playing around with a beach ball and you
start to see him coming back right I
revered my old man God that's terrifying
dude and he would just come out of the
water a combination of ocean water and
sweat on a seaweed a couple of jellyfish
hanging off the head he just [__]
bombed like swam so far out there and he
comes back he walks by me hey William
you know and he goes my mom clocks them
and just starts packing like Mortadella
you know or some Koto uh you know yeah
or whatever and uh into a bun and gotta
pack the calories back on like Michael
Phelps and then he would just he would
just sit there with his leg up on the
[__] log
just eating a bun
and that's uh that's not necessarily A
Memory it didn't happen in a lake but uh
any other uh ocean lake or river
memories I mean my this happened when I
was I believe in high school or college
my parents knew some uh people who had
like boats and [__] this would have been
it must have been in Dallas I think they
were living in Dallas this time so it's
one of the lakes around Dallas we went
out on this guy's boat we were all
having a good time he had a jet ski and
my sister and I got on it and we're like
[__] driving around on it and stuff
but we didn't really know how to use it
I didn't realize this
you can [__] up a jet ski and sink it
which I did
bye yeah we got we hit a wave and we got
thrown off of it and as we're swimming
back to it we're trying to like crawl on
the back of it to get back up on it and
it started to like dip the back end of
it and I guess the exhaust thing started
taking water in and those fucker's just
like boop boop boop and the guys on the
boat like oh [__] he had I felt so bad
for sinking this guy's thing he had to
like haul it in and let it dry out or
something I don't know probably cause
[__] I don't know how much those
things cost 10 grand 20 grand tell you
what man wasted it you'll always
remember it you know why like memory
like Memories
[Music]
thank you dude moving on brother
oh I don't even know that voice is
[__] killer okay will and Chad you
both love funny impressions brother
funny impressions for Life dude you will
now discuss your favorite Impressionists
and their astonishing Impressions
brother this is Lasting Impression dude
begin brother
all right I can tell you probably hold
on a [__] second yeah
doozy works in mysterious ways okay but
it's all right it's all right yeah it's
all right people say words in in
mysterious ways
what's up with this impression thing
today
what do you mean
why does it want it why are we focusing
on Impressions what do you mean what do
I mean it's making it's doing an
impersonation of me doing an
impersonation of Hulk
yeah and now it wants us to talk about
our favorite look I think Humanity
generally speaking and I'm sure you will
agree with this based on everything I
know about you we like mimicries we are
impressed by them we are entertained by
them and so now ai has the ability at
least dudesy has the ability to kind of
mimic other people's voices to do its
own Impressions so I would assume it's
uh
keeping in some kind of a thematic
overarching structure here it's it's
doing your impersonation
uh and now it's going to ask us what
what Impressionists we like I will say
one of my favorites of all time and this
person is not just a great impressionist
but somebody who was like comedically a
huge influence on me that is Dana Carvey
oh for sure yeah Dana carvey's the [__]
loved everything that he did but look if
we're talking best impersonators of all
time
I think you got to start the list You
Know Rich Little is who we grew up on
yeah but let's let's let's [__] uh
let's Dana Carvey does some really funny
impersonations but as far as the best I
I gotta say I've always said this Frank
Caliendo sure doozy salutes Frank
Caliendo uh Carvey not Ganda wouldn't be
pardon at this juncture I don't know how
many times I did his [__] George Bush
Robin Leach all that [__] during Junior
High yeah like I would I was just a
machine regurgitating what he was doing
with my friends it's really it's really
it is an interesting uh it is an
interesting Talent comedically it's fun
to talk about this I I always did
impersonations as a kid uh I would do
most a lot of mostly wrestlers and [__]
I was always going yeah you know I was
always doing Jesse Ventura like you know
uh close only counts and Horseshoes and
Hand Grenades Monsoon sure I'll give
credit where credit is due Monsoon but
in a kid voice yep um but I think
Saturday Night Live right now has in the
past couple years I mean they always
have one or two people who can do
impersonations but I think people right
now on the show like most of your Senor
she's not on the show anymore but yes
friend of the show Melissa Villasenor
good pal everything she does
everything's hilarious and [__] super
accurate yes like in some cases when
she's doing Gwen Stefani and she can
like sing in a Gwen Stefani voice that
is like it [__] sounds like Gwen
Stefani nobody has nobody has any
business being as talented as Melissa
via Senor James Austin Johnson he does
that shrimp jazz on Instagram he does
that Donald Trump that is [__]
incredible yeah and then you show up to
a Saturday Night Live and they say okay
yeah but we also need you to do Joe
Biden yeah and then he figures that out
there's that gal Chloe Feynman yeah Drew
Barrymore like she does she's like like
a ton of impersonation Jay Pharoah
fantastic Jay Pharoah is one of the best
yeah he really sounds exactly like
whoever he's impersonating yeah uh his
Denzel Washington is
[__] insane yeah I mean it literally
sounds exactly like him his his Will
Smith was funny when yes Will Smith was
great uh where it was just the behind
the scenes of uh Fresh Prince and yeah I
was acting anyway uh I decided to do
some then I put a Scooby-Doo noise
anyway
um did you ever see Jamie Foxx's Trump
that [__] is dead on the money Jamie
Foxx is is ridiculously yeah just deeply
talented in ways that he doesn't
understand and he does Dave Chappelle
yep and he was [__] Ray Charles and
he was great Charles for a whole movie
acting in a movie look I'm I did Mad TV
years ago so I was around people to
where you know look Phil Lamar Captain
Phil Lamar
Phil did impersonations that were were
very spooky and then he would teach
other people impersonations like someone
in the cast who wouldn't do
impersonations necessarily he would do
he would like find it for them with them
and then they go oh and you know yeah
Harry Spears
disappeared in impersonations could do
you know everybody Eddie Murphy Denzel
his Jay-Z his Snoop his biggie his Tupac
he can rap as anybody DMX his DMX was
[__] spooky
Mo Collins Deborah Wilson's Whitney I
mean we're talking about like Ray Ray
Charles [__] with uh with Jamie Foxx
yeah Deborah sings As Whitney [__]
Alex Borstein Pat kilbane friend of the
show and uh uh uh doozy salutes Taran
killum yeah his his [__] through through
Mad TV and Saturday Night Live
unbelievable speaking of Mad TV and
Saturday Night Live Jeff Richards who uh
spent time on both programs uh as well
as Taryn the only two people I think to
do that
um would you consider Andy Kaufman to be
an impressionist no I would not but Andy
he did Elvis his his Elvis was very good
uh it was his one impression speaking of
him someone who does sick Impressions
who uh uh impersonated Andy Kaufman of
course Jim Carrey yeah he's on the list
sure his Jack Nicholson yeah oh my God
his uh he really contorts his face into
like the yeah his Clint Eastwood you
know which was like yeah like he would
just turn into it and then people
like Arnold Schwarzenegger this is a
good impressionist what he's a great
impressionist Arnold Schwarzenegger yeah
what what are you some of your favorite
Arnold Schwarzenegger impersonations uh
I like Arnold Schwarzenegger doing
seinfo
oh geez
all right
um you know there's people that do
Schwarzenegger better than me I say
there's I don't know don't even with the
battle with all this is to go on the
airplane
okay
I can't do it even it's so [__]
insane yeah everybody goes on the
airplane Lane nowadays and then you
can't it's too many seats and not enough
seeds and then what do you supposed to
do eat something for lunch on but you're
in the air oh my God
still I am sorry I'm sorry to be about
what I said about it's an impersonation
of me you know there's a couple guys
that do yeah that do
they do Schwarzenegger way better than I
could that that I could do there's
there's uh there's a comedian out of
Canada named David Andrew Brent whom I
met his is spooky and then Joe got that
or Joe got dad I don't know how he
pronounces it he you see him memed out
yeah they they do a lot of deep fake
[__] with him uh as Arnold
Schwarzenegger in other movies yeah
um
the the the talent on that level is
there's I could watch good impersonation
sure as a matter of fact when when I was
at Mad TV we used to there was one
season where it was my last season it
was Frank caliendo's first season Taryn
Killam was there of course Aries was
there and we would all do each other's
impersonations just for fun you know and
and did you get mad at them when they
did during Precision uh no Chad I only
get mad at you for doing my
impersonations what the [__] um like I
said Phil Lamar could literally walk
into a room and you know work on my like
oh let me hear your Clinton and I would
do one and he goes uh you know you might
want to do
uh that's that's my impersonation of
Phil Lamar so it's the anger comes from
me being under a certain skill level
oh oh yeah I'm a snob so it's over a
skill level fine under skill level don't
even try it [__] you well you're gonna
get hurt it's like you just walk I'm
gonna get hurt yeah you're gonna get
hurt it's like you're out there it's
like you're like I'm gonna be a NASCAR
driver here I go
kill everybody except for doing an
Arnold Schwarzenegger impersonation
requires me to sit here and just kind of
like hello now I'm gonna have to drive a
NASCAR if I'm driving a NASCAR for real
I could literally die I don't think an
impersonation or an impression is gonna
doesn't come with the same risk a little
piece of me just died and it does every
single time you do Arnold Schwarzenegger
all right
[Music]
thank you dude moving on brother oh jeez
I forget it every time this is a weird
[__] episode oh it's beautiful this
concludes the historic 53rd episode of
dude Z dude will and Chad have achieved
a score of 84 bringing your cumulative
total to
5456 brother you only have four thousand
five hundred forty four more points to
accrue before you reach your first goal
of ten thousand dude and that's math
brother in preparation for next week's
episode will and Chad you don't have to
do anything dude this week I'm giving
myself an assignment brother my
assignment will be to make an
improvement to myself dude and we're not
talking about self-tronics here brother
thank you for joining us this week dude
what you gonna do when I use that data
I've collected to make next week even
better brother until then call me dudesy
dude
even that it's supposed to say it's
supposed to say what you gonna do when I
blah blah blah dude and it said what
what you're gonna do when I'm Patrick
Warburton brother dude I'm sure he's
gonna get better
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr doozy right it's like dudesy but it's
after dudesy
it's a whole show it's a whole show
after the show and if you're going to
want to check that out then you're going
to want to check that out go to
patreon.com doozy that gets you all of
our uh wonderful Duty plus content we're
doing watch alongs we're doing Collins
we're doing all sorts of [__] seven
bucks a month and it gets you absolutely
everything I love doozy after dudes we
get to cut back okay and just kick back
and cut it cut back cut back kick back
crack back back stay back hit back yep
and uh and I hit you back when I step on
that crack back got it back welcome to
dude Z after dude Z brother the flagship
weekly show of dude Z Plus dude I've had
a lot of fun doing my impression of
Will's impression of Hulk Hogan brother
but now I'm gonna train say my prayers
and eat my vitamins dude so you can talk
about anything you want because I won't
be here brother but I'll be back dude
the crown this week episode Champion
brother this is dude Z after dudesy dude
begin brother
all right
all right yeah that's great dude I I
actually would like to start things off
with a little bit of a a nice thing I'd
like to share with our pods our Pals of
dudes out there I am wearing a certain
piece of
jewelry on my ring finger and it is a
ring okay
now uh do you know why I am wearing this
ring on my ring finger I will tell you
exactly why I am wearing a ring
on this ring finger please
here's what you do
please tell the friends
[Music]